adorada por unos detestada por otros
margaret thatcher la primera mujer en el
mayor cargo político británico no dejó
indiferente a nadie y llevó a profundos
cambios al Reino Unido la líder del
partido conservador llegó al puesto de
primera ministra en 1979 en medio de una
crisis económica y de continuas huelgas
de trabajadores la que era conocida como
La Dama De Hierro luchaba contra el
comunismo y era una ferviente defensora
del liberalismo económico también era
conocida por dirigir el país con
intransigencia varios eventos claves
tanto en política nacional como
internacional marcaron sus 11 años en el
poder en 1982 thatcher emprendió una
guerra contra Argentina por la posesión
de las Islas malvinas un enfrentamiento
que le dio la victoria Y aunque hubo 900
muertos le permitió ser reelegida en
1983 la primera ministra también hizo
frente a una larga huelga de mineros en
1984 que criticaban la supresión de
miles de trabajos pero thatcher no se
dio y después de un año de batalla
social los mineros regresaron al trabajo
sin haber obtenido nada la era thatcher
estuvo marcada por la casi destrucción
de los sindicatos las grandes
privatizaciones que llenaron las arcas
del estado y el aumento del desempleo
también se destacó en la lucha por los
intereses británicos dentro de la
comunidad europea con su famosa
expresión
devuélveme mi dinero y logró bajar la
contribución británica al presupuesto
europeo finalmente fue el voto de un
nuevo impuesto local en 1990 lo que
marcó el fin de su mandato y la obligó a
dimitir dejando como legado la imagen de
una personalidad controvertida